okay all right we switch game Safari
maybe look at that big boy is this
pokemon snap oh my god no
[Music]
the graphics look terrible oh my [ __ ]
god
[Music]
oh my god I've been waiting for this it
came out in this trailer in 2000 I've
been waiting for [ __ ] 20 years are
you kidding me I don't know why they
didn't do it on three days it doesn't
make any sense to me why they didn't do
it on 3ds holy [ __ ]
pokemon snap which was released
unintended 64 oh my god there's ago is
coming to it what new switch in a whole
new way this switch is a perfect
platform for this we're also developing
a new pokemon snack for Nintendo's
switch we look forward to sharing more
details with you see come on go we need
to I love Pokemon go and I still
consistently play but we need to stop
right here pokemon snap look it's not
even that good okay nobody's saying that
it's a fantastic game but the [ __ ]
nostalgia of that game and trying to
find every single Pokemon with the
different combinations of things when I
was a kid I think I was like six when I
played it I was the math checks out oh
my god that's like the biggest nostalgia
boner you ever could have given me what
a brilliant way to just start my morning
you know that is way shorter than I
thought too so there's gonna be a really
short video oh my god I'm very happy I
feel like you could go through a million
old IGN videos and be like just any time
anyone is like Ilana what came do you
want to see come to the Nintendo switch
and like pokemon snap holy [ __ ] I happen
to be wearing the shirt today I mean I
did know that the Pokemon direct was
today so it's cheating but I feel like
it came through even my green screen
bulbs [ __ ] up sorry buddy ah it's
gonna be a good day it's gonna be a good
day